this week we are crammed in our studio
with our two wonderful guests Christine
and Elijah do not go on a podcast or you
will be uncomfortable really quickly
thank your sponsors for the podcast we
have lift this week guys lift is looking
for drivers right now lift can pay up to
35 an hour you make your own hours
really great all you need is a car right
now go to lift calm slash Gemma Julian
to get started and you can get with that
you are a $500 driver bonus which is
awesome also this week we have naturebox
guys you know how much we love naturebox
they are some of the best-tasting and
also really really great snacks that
don't make you feel guilty about
snacking right now you get 50% off your
first nature box or by going to nature
box calm down in Julian I'm thinking
sconce and just tear the constant guilt
yeah about what are everything for just
exist wife okay I'm sorry
just sorry relieve yourself of the guilt
there needs to be no guilt okay so
hopefully you guys sounded these are for
something using gloves on the podcast
but whatever it is betterment what's
good to me it sounds good I experienced
opinions by third bucket your experience
on the Jenny Lee podcast so really
quickly a little introduction
you guys are internet peeps like
ourselves and you guys are quite awesome
nameís yeah a little more subscribers
here when they say well name a more
iconic duo you guys are the more I got
yeah so you guys are now flogging
together yes yeah yeah so you vlog how
many times twice a week yeah we start
off doing one a week but like it was
like okay maybe we can do two and now
they were doing you were like we can't
do any one Yeah right that's that's
exactly it yeah as well struggle oh I
get it and you guys are always finding
yourselves in very funny precarious
situations which one of which I was
involved you had your first Elijah I had
my first Elijah Christine moment and I
like to enroll with the cool kids
I saw comments like oh look at Julian
he's so cool pretty edgy it's okay yeah
and you guys both would you use that you
did a lot of Twitter but you started on
vine right that's right now okay and you
would say you started pretty nice there
and okay so you guys met each other
though was like through Twitter yeah he
was on a grinder actually hell yeah
that's fun how did the first exchange go
do you remember um I just you tell
because I was I was working because I
had a marketing company that was running
and so like I was doing social media
marketing for a ton of people and they
wanted her to meet her they want to be
top Gillick influencers for it and so I
was like alright we have to talk to this
girl cuz like she's because you only had
like 50k on bite or something and I was
like she's got bloke quickly cuz like
Oliver shits into a ton of likes and so
we started working with her I don't even
think you end up doing I never know we
just be really good we just became front
and then he quit the company is like
bring us together served its purpose
yeah yeah and where you guys from
I'm originally from Detroit Chicago
Chris Hondros similair okay and you guys
didn't know each other when you were
there nah wild okay cool and so I have a
really quick really [ __ ] random thing
were you in San Francisco in December of
25 14 you know Christine you no never
been you've never been told you [ __ ] you
ha ha ha wait why cuz we're at this
hotel in services I think it was
December 2014 drunk homeless girls
throwing up everywhere I swear there's
this growing lobby and I was like that
is Christine stuff right my dad and I
was like Julian no it's
so [ __ ] hurt like you have a you have
a twin somewhere no you cannot my memory
does not fail me other Christine I saw
her maybe from home alone it was my
pigeon she [ __ ] rules a lot a lot of
times on Twitter people like I saw your
twin and I'll look at the picture it's
just a fat person we both have like
rounders like I don't get it
thanks for that observation yeah really
good that's where a person yeah I love
how quickly she just didn't even have to
think about it nope never been I cannot
let you go it's not old you know i watch
i want to go up for my birthday because
we're going to Puerto Rico for his
birthday time on a birthday trips when's
your birthday
ah generate 900 years it's ooh I don't
like the ulema deal yeah run Buster
month we feel nobody were to stay Tom's
going to oh oh wow oh yeah let's go and
we I think we all first met at that
party at VidCon yeah daddy yeah late
night at Denny's trashed divine part it
was a vine party yeah and I was talking
to you I remember the first time I met
at that party and your show me your
tattoos which is really awesome
collection defenses but you're
specifically showing me the Trump
tantrum point which i think is kind of
like obviously you are known for that
tattoo especially how did that tattoo
happen um I was coming down off acid and
just got it so it's a tattoo of Donald
Trump sucking a dick yeah it's a day it
is MW I like my tweeted it that I would
do it for like it was a low number of
read was like five five feels like five
oh yeah I was just like out cuz I'll
definitely get away I was going to touch
it either way yeah but I just did a low
number just so like I had an excuse to
do it yeah that happened in like an hour
and I was like are you gonna go do it
they did yeah so I booked it and there's
when I think about like two days later
to get it or something stupid it wasn't
that long after did the person that was
like doing it were they
what happens when he gets tattoos she
actually offered oh yeah so I knew Chris
Saint who does piercings yeah different
TV so he was like he saw the tweet news
was like you have to come to get it done
my shop I am Scott who cuz she really
want to do it she thinks is hilarious
I'd she's like a lesbian she's never
seen a dick before oh yeah she wants to
draw it just like freehand and I'll do
it so she like drew up a dick it's
pretty detailed for never seeing a penis
before Yeah right
truth yeah the previous yeah yeah yeah
Chuck it's veiny yeah and that tattoo
did it happen before after the fanfic
those after I was after yeah I was like
like two months after I think okay so we
actually read your fan thick on this
podcast yeah yeah we read your Donald
Trump answer it's incredible I've never
read it
you never [ __ ] good I read an excerpt
on vine oh that's right I read like
studentís I was like I never like really
ready because I was like oh that's a lot
like I don't know like I don't know sit
down we got on the podcast and we flew
through and I was like this is so good
yeah it's like today just long yes why
it's so dumb so if you want to see go
back to the fanfic podcast and the
Donald Trump what is it called
I'm the bellboy Trump Temptations here
like so he wrote he wrote that and you
were on all sorts of like media outlets
yeah as of it yeah it was on the news
like the EPA pick like you brought you
brought you on Fox News uh Bullock I've
released in the night because I got em
today
and then like like if I if I think
something's funny like I'll tweet it
like if I have a funny idea I'll tweet
it just people will like hold me to it
but I have to do it girls I won't do it
again
like I have the worst drive for anything
and so I tweeted that I was going to do
it and then people wanted it so I wrote
it in like four hour three hours or
something I wasn't there but he was like
texting me he's like I'm just writing it
okay what are you writing I think I'm
just writing it is super super high
super drunk wrote it and then like they
like you just release a book now they
just let anyone's four hours is up and
Nestle like what's the process to make a
book well you don't you just write it
and then you save it and I just awful of
it we're did you analyze Amazon games on
yeah so you like upload the text and you
put up like a cover you like yeah you
have to say there's like a PA
PDF or whatever okay and use upload it
and then get your cover artwork my
roommate was like I want to design the
cover art so my god did they like
Photoshop and [ __ ] yes a Nick design the
cockroach and he was just like he caught
like this dominatrix in the background
okay I've been like that dominatrix
actually hit me up no way I was like hey
I know you use my photo for this book
but I don't care because it's so funny
oh yeah there's a super chill with and
it was really funny as you ever run into
any issues with like using Trump's name
or face or anything no he did he stayed
pretty quiet I know he knows what it is
we stayed pretty quiet yeah cuz he wants
to keep reading go away yeah if you want
to see qualities like yeah he's really
the low-key loves it I want to see fine
copy baby you guys are the like didn't
you get kicked out of a rally yeah yeah
we got it
yeah like did we had obtained my service
okay when you go on so we went to we
both got an emailer on phone to be
signed up for like his rallies was
really we should go to rally we both got
the alert look at the same time that he
was coming to Nevada and we were like
and we showed you guys Vegas we're like
oh we have to go and everybody knows
about to do sorry to Nevada what the
[ __ ] is that
I was like bye Reno yeah yeah ever like
should we still go all right let's just
go you know actually we did like we did
some kind of like energy show like this
and then from there left and just drove
through the night today I got eight our
drivers from showgirls is on of our
Louise chocolate going lol what who's
Barney who's Claude whoever's the Tom
dominant want us him
I see I've actually seen that dynamic in
action whoever sidewalk is having your
vlogs are like Christine no no there's
no doctor yeah yeah yeah I like the
peach yeah no that's it sounds like it
okay all right so you drive through the
night to get other alley well we were
like we were trying to figure out what
we were gonna do that night like because
really we have to go Israeli what are we
gonna do that would be funny oh yeah oh
man that'd be funny and we were like I
think we looked over there's a dildo in
the counter me like we have to throw a
luau oh my god so we went to has a
Pleasure Chest another shout out
Pleasure Chest and we uh got use code
Trump for $30 off we got a we got a
dildo and we were like well we have to
get his bout back up one so get to about
we're like well what if I miss you need
ammo yeah my god it's like so you know
whatever it's like six o'clock yeah we
waited in line for like we are you
kidding you probably know we put them we
were when we're getting out of the car
we're like we were gonna put these like
they're not gonna fit our pot Lee was
near a big dildo yeah and of course they
were yeah and then I was just like all
right what she goes why just put in my
pants and stuffs in her pants no she's
like very confident you know I feel it
you know
yeah it's comfortable so I had the
bigger one and I'd like wrap it around
and then it was it was it was in there
and it was staying and then we waited in
line for like six hours like five Modelo
in you can go for dinner where it's like
with a bunch of like redneck people like
oh yeah it looks like Walmart on Black
Friday like like and they had like this
one kid was like dressed up in like a
full American flag like suit when like
grandpa oh yeah the kids like six years
old really clearly he wants to be in bed
like it's six o'clock Minori take that
poor child home yeah and then we like we
kept waiting in line and like it was it
was pretty cold out but like between our
legs it wasn't cold so like if that
would have hit him like five hours
between our legs with those dildos would
like he was warm yeah
I was sweaty about that yeah but we were
like one of the first people Maya yes
bro so we were in the front right oh
yeah we like blasted their security they
even [ __ ] Pat us down yeah and we
said we went right like we're directly
as far as this cop is what was the
podium no and I was just like oh and I
tweeted a picture of it like just the
podium and nothing else and like so many
people were like flipping out with my
daddy tell travel Trump's our timetable
was Tatooine fanfic has it happen the
fanfic was like end of January early
February and then the tattooing mark and
then this was this was dogs in like
February this was in February so this
was between the two yeah yeah yeah cuz
so cuz tattoo is the last new you got it
the middle it's just hard to sort
through all your trumpet antics so funny
yeah but so anyway I think what we did
was ice in front of him yeah we try to
pretend that we didn't know each other
and I I'm like oh she had wanted her
pants yeah yeah she was like a bad
complain good yeah I mean like what was
gonna happen if we get arrested yeah and
she was just like she's like I'll do the
second one like I was a gay you throw
the second one if I miss yeah so he gets
out there and then all of a sudden okay
that was my favorite right here behind
me are you Elijah and he goes uh yeah I
turn around
three guys in suits I should have seen
me act like I didn't know this guy I go
like oh my god this is before you
through anything don't you see that I
ate it I tweeted the picture the podium
and so many people flipped out that's
not a big shadow chose anything tracked
yeah yeah so I just your end like I like
playing I tell myself it's cuz like oh
just if I don't wanna get caught too
because then I could still throw the
dildo no it was like I don't wanna get
chosen I don't know who's gonna sing Oh
what did you what did you think was
gonna happen to him I thought he
arrested I was like it up but he they
let him keep his phone so we were
texting each other and I'm like should
throw it like should I still throw it
yeah I don't like do you don't want to
do that
it's getting like interrogate he's like
I didn't even throw it yet and like this
is awful do not throw it yeah
and says like okay and then um and then
this is a unrelated but I was just like
farting so bad in that cracker was so
fun like to the point where even when I
was saying everybody around us was like
do you [ __ ] smell that and I'm like
yeah I don't know it was like it's
Robert Malley I would have held it in
but ya don't use for Charlie yeah
they'll eat at on my shoulder and
they're like are you Elijah Daniel and I
was just like - defense Artillery now
I'm like don't don't like that that was
a phase yeah so like yeah that's why
she's like did you think I was like
don't [ __ ] this up for me I just like
four guys in suits I was like hauling
[ __ ] right now oh my god and I was
like oh you're like yeah I'll take a
picture later and yeah like yeah yeah
it's the mug shot I feel like they like
walked me out like grabbing my arms and
like walked it is sketchy like Godfather
kitchen why they were they talking to
your own mom they were like they come as
they were like interrogating me on my
way there like asking me what I was
doing there while I was there Wyatt we
did like the scripted cryptic picture
along with because my next duel cuz I
mean that's cryptic did you show the
picture the way what do you even work
yeah did you like comically I'm not
about to dildos
yeah they don't show so you just told
them that you were just there oh yeah oh
we just thought we were just gonna like
yell something funny ahem they uh they
brought me into the back room and they
like salvington out and I'm like so
uncomfortably sat there with like my
legs it's a giant oh no no my legs and
they're like why are you here and I'm
like I uh
we were here to heckle on precision and
he was like you're for snapchat oh yeah
we get views on snapchat so we were just
gonna heckle him and he's like well why
did you tweet last night probably gonna
get arrested tomorrow and I was like I
was like because I thought you could get
arrested for hackling and he's like no
you can't and I was like oh that's weird
I thought you bad so I just made really
stupid and then they pulled up you
stupid really well yeah yeah and they
pull out this like folder and I had like
a slick a printed out black-and-white
photo of my book cover oh my god along
with like my twitter like screenshotted
like all of this [ __ ] and then like all
of my tweets about Trump or like sweet
generous guy so they had a file
oh yeah well that's in ten I was like oh
[ __ ] and so they kept they like pulled
out this whole thing with his like
questionnaire it was like a hundred and
something question no [ __ ] I was back
there for like 30 minutes probably 45
yeah yeah it was close to that and then
they like they went through all these
like really personal questions and like
I just was just like personal in the
sense that they were prying or they had
information prying they were like asking
about like my family I was like trying
to get any original Eden Rd yeah and so
there was a stupid [ __ ] and like stuff
they already clearly knew so I was play
answered all their questions I was like
[ __ ] I didn't do anything so I'm good
yeah and um they were like are you with
anyone and I was just like I know they
know I'm with someone because I have a
picture was walking it yeah that's
stupid and I was like oh yeah my friend
I know where she is I think she might
play I think we lost her on it and she's
I'm like as I'm like this or and I was
like oh yeah oh yeah text her Toto meet
us out front and then he was like oh did
she text back yet and I was like oh yeah
it was like fake texting her and then
she would show through it early um and
then they like had me go outside and
meet Christine and then they
interrogated her as around my well-being
does he like is he is he mentally
unstable and I hope everybody was like
well I mean like who is it worst answer
she could say like they wanted to
interrogate her separately and I was
just like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] I go
to jail now no see that should it pretty
good
I didn't yeah I mean typically you
ratted me out yeah but you you already
did that because you knew that they knew
you were together it would have been
blatant lying
I decided I give him our time yes so
there's something there to snapchat yeah
so they'd be ahead find out so the
Secret Service y'all if you're watching
this they would they had dildos they
were really like don't know their jobs
guys o-town and then two days later we
were we were filming a video in my
apartment and they were like and like
somebody banged on the door really hard
and like I don't have the Spurs ever and
my roommates like oh it's probably
Secret Service and then I look up the
[ __ ] peak hole and there's do guys no
suits and I was like are you serious
they came to your house
I freaked out oh we got it working basis
oh it gets way worse than that so like
they they like came and like asking
follow-up question all [ __ ] no gonna
take a look Ryan apartment was like any
times it and so but for my apartment cuz
we video minute oh yeah right oh yeah I
like they didn't have a search warrant
so I was just like oh you can walk
through notes well you're just buttering
yeah so I just walk them through real
quick and then they start getting like
really pushy like kinda cool just
blatantly filming though she's filming
of like getting like cool like shots to
the peak holder like why why did they
think you wanted to make sure I didn't
have any weapons attack mercifully they
show up was it with relation to you guys
showing up at the rally oh yeah it was
so fun yeah follow up yeah so after that
I'm not saying it's like ranting us are
you yeah yeah after to two days after
that like they came to search whatever
they left and then two days after that I
woke up to like 14 missed calls from my
mom oh god he somehow got her father
know and then went to Michigan oh my
[ __ ] god and they like kept calling
Harley over and over again like try get
her to come to the office and then she
was just like go to the office like I
really care and so she went into like
the Secret Service office in Michigan
and like talked to them and had like
this whole conversation about my well
being really solid and they're just like
there's like is he mentally stable she's
oh absolutely not
but like he's fine oh yeah works it yeah
point he wasn't the president he was
just running yeah and they're doing this
level of well they haven't [ __ ] on you
or like looked up tomato at him yeah
also really just to like just like like
from a completely third party view you
have a big following in the Internet and
you constantly trash it oh yeah which is
like if I'm the Secret Service yeah I'm
gonna keep an eye on you I don't know
that level of Schilling to your mom's
house audience which I had were like
super cryptic and creepy like they were
definitely some yeah I don't have to
understand that but yeah the means that
they took were were justified it was
shitty but Lee was also like okay
yeah and then nothing came of it so the
day left your primary refine after my
the whole Mon thing to enjoy them my mom
like my mom was like oh hey I got his
number we were texting like we're
praying for each other I was like why
are you friends with the Secret Service
no it's like a prayer chain Oh like the
church grip thing they go to church they
like good morning brunches like I am
like I suppose we forget that we did
that yeah and that's like that's almost
normal for us like that seems like shays
a [ __ ] all the time
don't forget I think that much of that
and then yeah so weird because like
literally no one would ever do that in
their entire lifetimes and then yeah
that creates oh it's like one of my
favorite story okay I told my mom
usually shouldn't even know and she's
like I'm glad I didn't come to me cuz
like she literally works for the US
government fired so yeah that's how we
threw almost threw a dildo a dog you're
gonna tell you I wish we had a grandkids
that you have together that that will be
the strength I wish I wish we got to
throw out though cuz it would have been
so fun already I'm like seeing it with
you in my head it was the universe it
was the first one of his rallies that
they live stream the entire thing I wish
I should have done this the first live
show and like but you say that now
and like you could have been really [ __ ]
yeah like you can't do it 1200 hour I
could have been at least if you saw a
dildo at the president you just get shot
yeah that's not something you could have
been yeah yeah I would have gotten shot
for a jump shot where shout Navy is one
type of gun seriously gonna be worth it
or right now just vomit oh my god it's
too real I got it
alright is this dark now we're gonna
take a very short break we're gonna take
a quick break about the sponsors we'll
be back in just a second all right guys
really quickly I want to let you know
our podcast this week has been sponsored
by lift right now ladies lift is looking
for new drivers and they are offering a
$500 driver bonus right now if you sign
up as a driver for lyft whether you're
an actor or actress that needs to make
money between jobs or you're looking for
a job right now
or maybe you're going back to school and
you
some free time here and there where you
could use some money lift is perfect for
you there are other ride-sharing apps
out there but everyone likes driving for
lyft best because they treat their
drivers right lots of people started as
customers and now drive for lyft it's a
flexible way to make money on your own
hours on your own time with your car
driving for lyft pays up to 35 an hour
and getting started as fast and easy you
can drive mornings nights weekends or
flipping the driver mode anytime you
have some free time then you want to
make some money plus only lyft drivers
can earn tips from within the app which
is super awesome because those add up
really fast and one more great thing is
you don't have to wait days or weeks to
get paid you cash out instantly with
Express pay so it all adds up guys it's
super flexible you keep your own tips
and you get paid when you need cash
right now you can sign up as a driver by
going to lift calm / annejulien
and you get a $500 driver bonus with
that URL that's lift calm / Jenna Julian
this episode is also brought to you by
nature box you guys know how great
nature box is they've been a longtime
sponsor this podcast nature box makes
hey do you want nature box or not nature
box makes great snacks that actually
taste great and are better for you
create with high-quality ingredients you
don't have to feel bad about snacking my
personal favorites are the Big Island
pineapple and I love the Mesa crisp I
cannot stop eating those they're
delicious nature box recently made their
service even better so you can order as
much as you want as often as you want
with no minimum purchase required and
you can cancel anytime
it's simple go to naturebox.com/tyler
Julian you can check out their catalogue
of over a hundred snacks sweet savory
they got everything you might want in
with nature box you'll never get bored
there new snacks each month that are
inspired by real customer feedback so
right now you'll save even more when you
go to naturebox.com/tyler Julian the
dink fan gets 50% off their first nature
box order that's naturebox.com/tyler
jelly and thank you to our sponsors and
back to the podcast now again we're back
we just talked about what you guys are
doing tonight yes really excited CheY
tell us or yeah so um it was actually
the night that we were at the tattoo
place right after you live yeah I get a
tweet and it is something else even
though
yeah so I get a tweet and I'm really
really into RuPaul's Drag Race like so
into it I just love it like drag queens
are like my celebrities like pretty like
nationalisms [ __ ] off yeah I feel
overdue genie back in the day you know
it's all about the drag queens so I get
this tweet from the sky not if not
Jackman he goes
Sharon Needles knows who you are knows
who you are and loves you just thought
you should know or something like that
I'm like magic she talked about Sharon
Needles like at least one today she gets
brought up or she quotes her yeah I ever
dyed it the Cheerios is Jack again
she's like number one or number two like
all-time favorites um I took a this
suite and I'm like yeah okay whatever so
I click on his profile and it says
Pittsburgh he's from Pittsburgh I'm like
Sharon heels for better sound like so
reply I'm like is this true and he goes
yeah she thinks she's really fun I'm
saying outfield is this true she's like
at this point crying in the shows like
freaking out so i DM him and I'm like
because he was like we should hang out
sometime and I was like I live in LA I'd
love that and he goes oh we're gonna be
there on Saturday for the Christmas
Queens tour uh here I'll put you on the
guest list for plus one and I go wow
like a circle just basically Cinderella
go into the ball I literally texted him
that I was like like rocket boy I said I
felt like Cinderella getting invited to
the castle except I'm fat everyone's gay
I'm an economy conscious to be their
conches when my favorite Queens
season 7 she was robbed she should have
won comment below
I feel like Alaska deserved their all
starts to win but caught you did really
well back atcha should have won season 7
I'm sorry violet chachki
I love your little outfit in the first
episode with the reveal and everything
but comedy Queens you own the world
conscious should one I'm done I second
that drama knocks over the table and
that's Hollywood right yeah that's
pretty cool but no both theater no both
you know I've never been there
shut ANOVA theater for sponsorship all
right so I have a game that I wanted to
put actually a couple games but this
game is called blocked or not ready or
mainly away
is mostly it's for Elijah yeah just like
that is blocked by Lee's block sorry
amount of a lot of really big all right
and I compiled a list of people I don't
know I didn't look into who you're
blocked by so I just randomly compiled
the list of people and I'm gonna read
them off and Jenna Singh the guess if
you're a blah blah minigame yes phone to
check you don't know cuz I don't know no
I don't want him to lie true okay no
yeah what's not checking are Bacardi
yeah are you cool guessing alright
alright Jenna's gonna guess if he's
blocked or not I have no comment and
then after the game if you have like
some notables that we miss you can let
us haha well there's a I have a question
off the top did you ever like make it a
point to try and get blocked by people
oh no I was just a really rude I was
very like I always would just be super
mean to terrible people
yeah um and then they were just under
blocking me tight I'm is always funny
means but like it was always me yeah um
okay
top of the list will get you know these
first year probably Donald Trump yes
totally
Jack Jack got a fact check so really
quick I have a question since we know
about all these events now when did he
block you 2012
oh so forever all forever ago I've
literally been [ __ ] with truck for
years anyway before brother yeah block
just tweeting relatively like The
Celebrity Apprentice or him mouthing on
oh I don't know he was he said my god of
the unfirm he is block somebody he said
something like homophobic or something
like that's so funny okay Jenny you have
to guess I'll tell you oh no um he
blocked me 2012 because like he says I'm
homophobic or something back then and so
like I would reply to every single thing
he tweeted yeah and just say buy me new
BMW I'm gonna tell I'm gonna tell the
world about our night in Japan or
something Jason Outremer it every single
time but I think that's crazy yeah in
Japan yeah
literally like that was what as a
bookkeeper I was like all that [ __ ]
blade that's why he blocks me maybe have
to let her guess yeah yeah okay so Jenna
is he blocked by lance210 oh yeah I'd
say yes I would say yes too I've gotten
in fights with yeah yeah get on your
list I want you to be blocked for him
maybe Lance doesn't like blocking people
really need to get ones my notable
people yeah Oh fair enough
he could have notable so Flynn Antonio
Oh what it's what I don't think I don't
think [ __ ] that pansies but I think I'm
ugly I'm blocked by Peaks I think I'm
like I am bought my pigs - you are but
you know I am okay he's not I am NOT
okay on your list I bought my peaks on
vine on black fight him on vine Twitter
and Instagram snapchat vine means you
can't watch his mind again um Tomi
Lehren is that I don't know how do I
tell me you know what she doesn't say
Lauren she's from my mom's hometown I
say he's not blocked no not a clock
anyone cookies she jail she did like my
tweet where I made fun of her though
she's a good Stewie
yeah but she doesn't but she doesn't
block anyone cuz she loves attention
she's there for
yeah there's getting me to me yeah yeah
Jacob Sartorius
I'd say the Elijah I would say not I am
NOT you know that is concentrat novel
that's right yeah amazing video thank
you for that hey Britt Vera
diviner trouble you tried I'm just like
victim is tomorrow's Lele pons oh my god
hold on your board I don't know but
you're a vine person so that makes more
sense yeah yeah now Nancy Grace oh I
might as fast you guys hurry up
do you think he's brought pedicures no
honestly I might be oh my god I've made
a lot of research wha
Dorian demo you're done
right well no I have story block you
can't steal my [ __ ] trees oh that's
smart
III think I'm blocked by the guy who
runs about common white girl is that the
same person I love my common white girl
I am black my car my car I was watched
by common white girls personal company
on block there's so many of its he's a
user now common ways on YouTube is gone
me and any way today yeah wait goodbye
YouTube Pony person did I who runs come
away cuz I gotta start a common white
girl I was treat like a girl what is
there who is that is that giant I need
oh I see anonymous like I caught away
that also Jack though here in the common
white girl cons that's so Jack Gabby
yeah Jack ban he runs the console
everyone's many more he started them
though so he do I actually need it I
gently tweeting sometimes was it him
that started the the culture of common
white girl stealing tweets or NZ I think
I just human nature
yes I'm the guy who loves sweet like a
girl you heard that right the guy guys
it's human nature to blatantly
plagiarized it's human nature to take
shortcuts and [ __ ] people to get
yourself ahead if I wasn't so naturally
hilarious I would die fair um [ __ ] Jerry
you think he's Marvis material mmm yes
oh oh yeah he actually follows me oh
[ __ ] well let me see if that's true
what about fat Jew yeah I walked on
Instagram I am but I'm that let his
platform he is blocked
he is blocked by [ __ ] up Jerry oh that's
tight sick um
alright we got two more Justin Bieber
I'd say no I'd say no no I don't think I
am doesn't seem like that account blocks
or does anything but follows people yeah
yeah that's our new EP two hundred
ninety six point nine thousand people um
okay last one Kim K yeah lot yeah yeah I
just want to see it I just want to say
it like well I want that to be my
background
yeah he [ __ ] me a long time ago did
she block you for oh I mean so many
jokes about her like so many oh no other
notable ones Chris Brown I got blocked
by him like Chris Brown and Kim
Kardashian on the same day that's a good
job Rick oh it was a good day
um it was during the Olympics of 2012
then Chris Brown tweeted something about
like son
does he feel like I know what it was
like he was like hardcore like into
skating or something and then he was
just like uh tribute a little bit so
it's stupid and I was just like oh I
don't think being women is actually a
sport there and then he like deemed me
and just said [ __ ]
and then blocked me and I was like I
didn't get to screenshot the [ __ ]
part like is he black - yeah the Box on
your screen shot don't come here yeah
so keep walking uh any other notables
that we missed I mean the reaction is
pretty great but you have like a
favorite person who's blocked you uh in
a favor last day my blog was important
blog uh I think it's it's Trump is my
mother my favorite one that's a pretty
damn good that's a really good one is
the coolest thing about you [ __ ] with
Trump is that you literally been the og
[ __ ] with trope guy yeah oh the Danny
Zuko is the og the guy who created
modern family he he's like one of the
funniest people like against rap he's
been doing since like 2012 at the same
time like 2012 yeah and like he got to
the point where Trump personally emailed
him and told the [ __ ] off like it's so
he told this story I was I did this like
Twitter document or anything with them
cuz like he he became really prominent
I'm gay too and so he was like telling
the story and I never even heard the
story before but he was like showing us
screenshots of the emails like Trump was
sending email like that was like Gmail
yeah cuz and then he kept like asking
why he doesn't like him and like all
this [ __ ] and he was just like dude like
I just don't have a guess about team on
TV yeah yeah that's so he's like he's
definitely one of the yeah that's yeah
that's interesting I did not know that
proud of you
love you dad I don't other notable ones
off the top of my head I'll block you
right now honey I said Noble um um I'm
editing zoom in on my face I made a
funny face I made a funny yeah I don't
know if you guys well obviously
everything that they do is in the
description their vlogs their Twitter
you'll go check that out but definitely
check out those tweets yes they're
pretty great let's let's round up this
podcast with a lightning round of
questions but the way it works is you
account for him okay I answer for
Christie Oh perfect so I'm gonna rattle
off I think I just twelve or thirteen
questions is where O'Neal
uh so um you go first so you're
answering for him okay so I'm gonna
rattle off these question have to answer
them fat okay I want make her really
nervous so she has to go fast eh there
you go favorite color
wait so you're answering fertilize these
are Elijah's answers blue what's his
favorite color blue if he could be an
animal snake ooh
favorite drink uh cactus schoolers
favorite food my god um oh my god I'm
not chicken tenders least favorite
person on the Internet Donnell chop
favorite person on the Internet me
please he wants to travel uh what are we
go the social media platform he hates uh
very interest favorite I agree with that
favorite Viner turned vlogger me
favorite vine of all time mine well yeah
which one which specific America miss
his target or um the discus T oh nice
not Chipotle order I know that because I
love you bully Rob Chuck cheeky chicken
burrito ball atop his Christmas list
until though
well done it was really good that's
fairly accurately I know where any of
those right or wrong I think was right
most all right yeah pretty well alright
have you said favorite Vilas Merry
Christmas actually one where she snorts
adderall
I don't start out my friend does that
welcome to Bible study yeah yeah
we should be that's the first time I
ever found you and I was like legend
it's like a mixture of that one and the
one where you kicked on the door the
dildo in your hand I have the audition
for ya
yeah it was more recently but when you
said square up Oprah I was like two
weeks like it's a fine of like almost
nothing like at a party and then you
just zoom in I think you go square out
of someone else's by yeah yeah yeah I
was [ __ ] tight let's go up okay so
Elijah you have a little bit of an
advantage because you've gotten to hear
the questions but still you got to be
fast and you got an answer for stress
teen ready go favorite color uh blue if
she could be an animal what animal
should be sea otter favorite drink oh
yes hell yeah uh coke it's not fireball
oh it's good cocaine alcohol not coke
God all right turn it off favorite food
damn I don't have it no angles Pringles
if you could be oh wait sorry hold on
favorite personally you're in it oh five
four three two [ __ ] I don't know who was
I just talking about Oh Sharon eat
almost no I got ya
Oh Katya wait those share needles no
sure nails with your drag queen Katya
Katya her twenties favorite person on
the internet Lele pons nice a place you
really want to travel to at our bedroom
probably just just crying there maybe
the couch like moving from the bed to
the couch that's the trouble with social
media platform she hates musically
musically okay favorite Viner turned
vlogger Zayn favorite vine of all time
let's get what look like ah your
favorite vine of all time is the one
where she goes [ __ ] Kara what it is
the one she find the spider in the fruit
aisle shoes what's up the coke yes and
she goes she lowers her lashes she goes
is that is that real
I start where tartar um you know really
drinkin tea not that caramelized Rama
bacon burger
Chipotle order uh you know in Chipotle
Chipotle and get Holland Dean what's
atop her Christmas list also a dildo ID
oh yeah my hair colors green what I say
blue blue oh I was gonna because I
always think your jackets like a blue
infinity
oh yeah I wanted to ask what's the story
behind the shirt is there sorry um I
just like it that's that's a great
answer cuz I wear shoes and you know and
I and I you know back in the day used to
mess of Texas so much now you not
reformed and it's just a reminder just
don't mess of a chicken on chickadees
dock sister mascot about that shirt so
much like random people on the street
random guys are like hey does it Texas
I'm like I never been I was like I went
to Corpus Christi when I was three like
I don't know like I don't care oh it's
so good thing I'm a cartoon character
because I just wear the same outfit
every day it's pretty I mean instead
occasion but I like the shirt so no
choice uh thank you guys so much for
coming honor is like a special event I
just again I have some on a whim I was
like - but cremator broadcast I love
that night you're super straightforward
it's like easy to hang out you guys
really fun I can come back anytime
seriously we should be podcast
hopefully the next time you come
whatever suitable like set for more peep
I like this set it's about it's close
yeah alright we're not doing [ __ ]
podcast mall just lay on top of each
other
yeah for sure looks like Jenga yes okay
well do human Jacob while they're
whispering make sure you guys check out
their vlogs they've logged twice a week
one of the days Thursday and my name is
Monday and Thursday on you she recently
got kicked out a drag show there are
vlogs that like stage drum and then
there are blogs there
genuinely [ __ ] crazy every same age
and we like we do some bits like the way
vlogging and another thing like that the
real [ __ ] you like though that's all
real you can write like [ __ ] generally
we'll be doing like well plants about
like oh we're gonna do this today and
we're in vlog and then like [ __ ] we'll
just go off the Romney we were going to
get a crazy tattoo of a [ __ ] Twitter
we bring the ball camp yeah we should
match the [ __ ] that yeah anyway um yeah
check their blogs out check them out on
Twitter we'll link it all below and yeah
please come back sometime yes they're
coming all right check out sponsors
below thank you guys we'll see you next
week for the podcast